das ist einmal mit ein paar dieser
bisschen verzweifelten friseurinnen im
moment sprechen nämlich mit renate klink
spur aus münchen mit celtic aus
hattingen und mit sabine klotz die
frisörin in mannheim ist ihnen allen
dreien schönen guten abend
wir sind jetzt gerade schon bei dieser
thematik altmaier hat gesagt er
schneidet sieht ja selbst zumindest
vorübergehend einige kollegen können das
nicht aber sie wollen ja vor allen
dingen wieder arbeiten frau klingspor
können sie uns einmal sagen ob sie oder
wie sie im moment schon vom staat von 1
altmaier von herrn scholz entschädigt
wir werden gar nicht entschädigt das
weiße altmann auch ganz genau
eigentlich wollte ich sie fragen ob wir
am 15 wieder öffnen
aber dieses habe denke ich hat sich
jetzt erledigt nach den aussagen
obwohl frau merkel immer gesagt hat die
ersten öffnen des lebens reserve bis in
schulen und kitas
ich wollte ihn auch immer fragen wie
steht es denn aus gibt es testergebnisse
aus denen hervorgeht dass nach dem log
dass sich irgendwelche menschen bei den
friseuren angesteckt haben oder
existiert habe bei dem punkt waren wir
gerade halt mal direkt an verein ja also
ich muss ihnen sagen ein großes
kompliment für die friseure die friseure
haben tolle sicherheitsvorschriften
gemacht hygienemaßnahmen abstände masken
alles hervorragend das hauptproblem
besteht darin dass wir verhindern müssen
dass zu viele menschen in öffentlichen
nahverkehrsmitteln unterwegs sind in
fußgängerzonen unterwegs sind sich nahe
kommen die sich nicht kennen und damit
das virus verbreiten das ist der grund
wir haben zu anfang nur die privaten
kontakte eingeschränkt dann haben wir
die gaststätten und die restaurants
geschlossen und am ende mussten wir
schweren herzens auch die friseure und
auch die modeboutiquen und die
bekleidungsgeschäfte schließen und dann
gingen die zahlen runter aber nicht weil
sie fehler gemacht hätten sondern weil
weniger menschen auf den straßen
unterwegs waren überzeugt sie das feuer
klingen spur
es ist natürlich bitter wenn man selber
alles gemacht hat und dann sagt man ja
ja die leute stecken sich halt in den
städten in den bahnen und bussen an und
deswegen muss sie ausschließen dass den
tisch
gibt es keine test wie irgendwelche
ergebnisse vor
dass die menschen sich bei den friseuren
angesteckt haben
ich habe noch keinen einzigen erlebten
die gesagt hat er ist ganz reduziert
worden
nein gut immer musst allerdings der
wahrheit die ehre geben und sagen dass
ungefähr 80 prozent der menschen nicht
wissen wo sie sich angesteckt haben
weil nämlich dieser test ja es positiv
ist mehrere tage 19 tage nach der
ansteckung und dann weiß der betreffende
eben nicht ob es beim einkauf im
lebensmitteleinzelhandel war in der s
bahn beim friseur oder anderswo und weil
wir so viele infektionen hatten konnten
die gesundheitsämter das auch nicht
rückverfolgen wenn es wenige gibt dann
kann man sagen okay du warst beim
friseur du warst im lebensmittelgeschäft
du warst im restaurant und jetzt schauen
wir mal ob du irgendwo in der zeit
infektionen aus natürlich für frau
klingspor ist auch vielfältig und frau
klotz eine ganz wichtige frage muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen kein mensch kann
sagen wir vermuten deswegen haben wir
komplett die ganze branche recht gemacht
aber beweisen können wir leider nicht
ganz wichtig wir haben nicht die branche
fest gemacht weil mein mann das sieht
man sich bei den versteigerungen
ansteigen sondern auch den weg dahin
genau so verstanden
nächste frage aber auch die müssen wir
auch ganz kurz klären von frau klinger
spur war nochmal fünfzehnter februar
noch mal ganz konkret das heißt folglich
spur sagt nee das war im grunde schon
neun von ihnen wird nein das nein ich
kann es doch ich habe es eben gesagt ich
selbst entscheide ist doch gar nicht es
kommen zusammen 16 ministerpräsidenten
die bundeskanzlerin und das halbe
bundeskabinett
und dann wird besprochen und dann wird
überlegt und es gibt wünsche bei den
kitas etwas zu tun
es gibt die frage bei den friseuren da
gibt es einen großen druck es gibt auch
welche die sagen es ist jetzt vielleicht
noch zu früh und wie das am ende dann
ausgeht das wissen werden wahrscheinlich
noch nicht mal am mittwochmorgen sondern
am mittwoch wenn die ministerpräsidenten
die kanzlerin zusammensitzen frau celtic
können sie uns können sie an altmaier
einmal ihre corona rechnung aufmachen
ja ich hatte mir mal guten abend erstmal
gut ich habe mir das auch punkte
ausgeschrieben ich wäre
glücklich wenn ich die loswerden können
die bei ihnen los geht's
ja es geht los die finanziellen hilfen
sind noch nicht da wir haben 0 1 waren
seit dezember aber bleibende kosten wie
einkommensteuer vorauszahlungen
umsatzsteuer miete etc
wir haben wirklich 0 1 kommen dann
kommen die hilfen wann wird ausgezahlt
wann wird uns geholfen wir sind
arbeitgeber
wir haben mitarbeiter die wir ja auch
noch irgendwo doch halten müssen
wir halten auch ich meine wir sind auch
freizügig sage ich meine ideen und
konzepte noch verschärfter zu machen
wir sind so nah an menschen und am
kunden dran die ärzte juristen
polizisten pflegepersonal das sind ja
schon berufszweige die geimpft worden
sind vielleicht sollten wir als nächstes
auch mit in die gruppe kommen dass wir
uns impfen lassen französische ganz
sicher wann kommen die hilfen lassen sie
uns erst mal da soll er also in ihrem
fall wenig überzeugt dass sie noch im
monat februar die abschlagszahlung
bekommen können
sie müssen den antrag stellen können das
ist geplant im laufe des februar dann
kommen innerhalb von ein oder zwei tagen
die abschlagszahlungen
das ist dann bis zu 50 prozent ihrer
fixen kosten maximal 100000 euro im
monat das erreicht nicht jeder weil die
unterschiedlichen die einen zahlen
mieter die anderen zwar keine ich will
aber vielleicht weil er alles konkret
ist sagen wir haben fünf milliarden
ausgezahlt seit ende november
für diejenigen die wir im november schon
geschlossen hatten und wir werden für
die wahl am 15 dezember geschlossen
haben jetzt ende februar mit den
abschlagszahlungen beginnen es gibt aber
jetzt schon die möglichkeit natürlich
ist er gut ist das schnell aus ihrer
sicht ja weil es geht ja darum es geht
ja darum dass wir pro betrieb bis zu 1,5
millionen euro erstatten
an kosten die diese betriebe haben und
die kommen schnell zusammen
und das kann man natürlich nicht auf gut
glauben und und vermutung machen sondern
das muss weil das geld der steuerzahler
ist ja in irgendeiner weise vom
steuerberater bei angefangen schweren
und großen geprüft werden und dann
entschieden werden aber ich will sagen
es gibt es gäbe ja für sie auch die
möglichkeit schon die ganze zeit die
überbrückungshilfe 2 in anspruch zu
nehmen und da werden fixkosten wie miete
und strom und wasser und heizung die
werden erstattet für die mitarbeiter
gibt es kurzarbeitergeld und das läuft
eigentlich schon seit dem ersten oktober
und wenn sie dann antrag gestellt haben
dann müsste das geld eigentlich da sein
oder in den nächsten tagen kommen und
das andere das viel günstigere was dann
noch obendrauf kommen weil wir ihnen ja
diesen lockdown noch zumuten mussten
das wird ende februar mit den abschlag
das heißt es ist eigentlich alles da sie
müssen sie noch ein bisschen geduld
haben frau klotz sagte er
der wirtschaftsminister und dann kommt
das schon wie sieht das bei ihnen aus
also normalerweise geschäftsleute müssen
ja immer pünktlich zahlen da wollen die
angestellten pünktlich das geld haben in
dem moment vielleicht kurzarbeitergeld
aber da muss eben die miete pünktlich
gezahlt werden und alle fixkosten die
man sonst hat und auf das geld vom staat
wartet man leider lange wie war es bei
ihnen frau klotz einen herzlichen
glückwunsch dass dieses jahres selbst
schneiden können leider ist es bei der
kundschaft nicht so bzw kurzer dank dann
ist es das ist es guter brauch ein brot
das geschäftsschädigend wasser altmaier
macht eigentlich nur eigentlich denn wir
nehmen uns der ganze handel mit humor
aber es muss auch mal gesagt waren das
ist einfach unsere existenz wir
verdienen unser geld mit dem
haareschneiden darunter leidet die
gesundheit liegt organe thema hier in
mannheim wird es höhere anzahl den 19 12
2020 schon geschlossen
das heißt unser weihnachtsgeschäft
komplett flügen und bis jetzt haben wir
keine gelder zum beantragen wir fangen
nicht in die überprüfungs hilfe 2 und
die überbrückungshilfe 3 ist erst zu
beantragen mitte februar
das heißt wir werden kein geld
fragen 50 prozent der in am
existenzminimum schon angelangt die
gesundheit den vorgarten thema aber es
müssten sie versprochene gelder einfach
liegen
ansonsten wird seine existenz stärkung
geben
und die wissen selber gute mittelstand
hebt den start
also ich verstehe warum das diesmal so
kompliziert ist es war im frühjahr macht
so unkompliziert die anträge okay jetzt
mal vereinfachen können
aber da ist es geld geflossen und dann
kann man überlegen und dann kann man
sagen es ist realistisch weil man es
noch ab jetzt sind ratlos
aber einmal habe unsere kollegen schon
termine gemacht
auf den 15 wie oft soll man das machen
muss so recht erschließen okay dann darf
eröffnung oder es wird noch leer
wenn ihr euch nicht niveau verspricht
denn da ist ja gar keine zeit mehr zum
planen
große organisationen das kann man sich
damit vorstelle rechnet einfach noch
etliches gestellten ruft ich versteh ich
verstehe sie wirklich weil ich auch in
meinem bekanntenkreis meiner familie
menschen habe denen es ganz ähnlich geht
wie ihnen und deshalb vielleicht der
frage zu der frage warum kann man das
nicht im voraus entscheiden weil wir
eben im voraus nicht wissen wie die
dinge sich entwickeln und dann müsste
man einen viel längeren lockdown
entscheiden um auf nummer sicher zu
gehen dass möchten wir aber nicht an
welche verzweiflung ja noch größer wir
können aber auch nicht sagen aber am
ende ist es ja genau darauf
hinausgelaufen muss man jetzt zumindest
in der rückschau sagen erst haben sie
gesagt nur für vier wochen immer wieder
nur für vier wochen diese
pressekonferenz gab es ja wohl wieder
das gesagt hat frau merkel das gesagt
hat der müller auch nur vier wochen und
mittlerweile sind wir bei 68 zahlen wir
haben gesagt wir machen ist für die
nächsten vier wochen weil im gesetz
steht länger als ehrlicher lachen dürfen
die länder das nicht um die
geschäftsinhaber zu schützen ich klar
ist man endlich genau die erwartungen
genau die hören
draußen war ja und dann war da muss ich
habe das heute auch bei ihnen in der
bild am sonntag gesagt im interview und
das teile ich mit winfried kretschmann
wir hatten zu anfang eben viel zu weiche
und lockere maßnahmen und trotzdem die
gaststätten geschlossen ab erster
november mit dem ergebnis dass die
infektionszahlen weiter nach oben
gegangen sind und dadurch haben wir zwei
monate verloren und das war ein großer
fehler
deshalb haben wir uns alle geschworen
dass wir öffnungen machen so schnell wie
möglich aber sie müssen verdreht das
auch nur in der rückschau umso mehr herr
altmaier müssen sie zumindest meiner
auffassung nach der anwalt von denen 3 1
sein und deren interessen vertreten und
die fühlen sich allein gelassen die
haben wir seiner teilweise keinen cent
gesehen obwohl ihnen zumindest teilweise
die hilfen zu stehen und wissen ja
überhaupt nicht wie das weitergeht aber
ich habe ich versucht er zu erklären
ich habe ich hatte im frühjahr die
soforthilfen ja vorgeschlagen und die
haben wir innerhalb von 14 tagen
ausgezahlt jedenfalls in nordrhein
westfalen und in berlin und in vielen
bundesländern
das waren insgesamt 13 milliarden für
drei millionen unternehmen und jetzt
geht da ging es aber um beträge bis zu
zehn oder fünfzehn 1000 d-mark nicht
mehr
und da werden übrigens jetzt überall
rückforderungen gestellt weil gelder
auch zu unrecht und zu hoch ausgezahlt
wurden
und jetzt geht es um beträge bis zu
anderthalb millionen und das ist etwas
was sie nicht einfach so überweisen
können wenn der antrag kommt weil ich
glaube dass alle die hier sitzen mit
denen wir diskutieren das sind ehrliche
unternehmerinnen die mit sicherheit
niemals falsche angaben machen
das sind halt eben nicht alle nur wenn
man zusätzlich ein sie hat man nur wenn
man ja übersetzt es ist die die
nachteile oder die umsatzverluste dieser
drei sind so hoch dass sie sich so
schwer tun das zu prüfen dass es bei
denen länger dauert ja aber das
natürlich aber dafür haben wir eine
haben wir einen keine lösung aber eine
hilfe
niemand muss zum insolvenz und konkurs
anmelden weil er die miete oder dass die
oder sonst etwas nicht bezahlen kann
wir haben extra das gesetz geändert und
haben gesagt bis ende april musste
niemand der eine solche hilfe bei an
backen kann klar insolvenz aber wovon
leben sie denn im moment frau celtic
wovon leben sie denn im moment wie wie
bestreiten sie ihren alltag haben sie
ihr erspartes etwas erspart hatte ich
natürlich meine alters man altert
ersparnis was ich halt hatte das ist
aber schon längst aufgebraucht also muss
ich einen kredit aufnehmen und das ist
nicht einfach zu zeiten kredit
aufzunehmen
ich hätte da noch ein vorschlag wir
bräuchten zumindest steuererlasse diese
zeiträume haben sie damals schon mal
darüber nachgedacht
ja es gibt steuerstundungen das ist
sache des kollegen scholz
naja dann trotzdem zahl was nutzen mir
das wenig stunden mache ich fange an zu
arbeiten
ich arbeite ich kann ich kriege ja gar
nicht ein ausfall so schnell wieder
eingeholt also muss ich dann gar für den
kredit arbeiten nein es ist es ist so
wir haben die stundungen ist ja das was
sie angesprochen hatten und ihre
kolleginnen dass die
steuervorauszahlungen machen müssen alle
drei monate
und das kann man stunden und dadurch das
ist weniger drückend zweiter punkt wir
haben einen verlust drückt rat
beschlossen schon im juni das heißt sie
können verluste aus diesem jahr an
rechten auf die steuern die sie im jahr
2019 gezahlt haben das war bis zu
4.000.000 das haben wir jetzt ausgedehnt
auf bis zu zehn millionen und das
bedeutet also wenn sie gewinne gemacht
haben im letzten oder im vorletzten jahr
dann können sie diese steuern die sie
gezahlt haben zu einem teil oder auch
ganz wieder zurückbekommen
ich habe manchmal auch das gefühl dass
wir nicht nur in der politik manchmal
langsam sind und zeit brauchen und ich
habe manchmal das gefühl dass die
beratung vor ort vielleicht nicht so ist
wie sie eigentlich sein sollte ich hatte
einen einen bekannten der hat gesagt er
ist durch alle durch alle prüf raster
gefallen weil irgend so eine klausel
verhindert hat dass er hilfe bekommt
oder nachweis gibt prüft man stellte
sich da stehe ich aber mein eindruck ist
dass in seinem fall gab es eine
sonderbestimmung und er konnte die hilfe
mein eindruck ist dass bald dreißig
super informiert haben
dass die drei genau wissen was sie ihnen
was sie ihnen zusteht ist zumindest mein
eindruck hier aus der ferne
was würden sie sagen wenn sie die
geschichte von frau klinger spur von
frau celtic von frau klotz hören
gehen sie davon aus dass ein oder zwei
von den dreien vielleicht in einem jahr
ihr geschäft nicht mehr haben
zwangsläufig ist es nicht weil wir ja
die hilfen beschlossen haben und die
hilfen kommen werden und viele hilfen
werden ja auch jetzt schon gezahlt zum
beispiel auch kredite wir haben diesen
800.000 euro sofortkredit auch für die
kleinen unternehmen möglich gemacht
schon vor einem halben jahr
aber was mir große sorgen macht ist dass
viele unternehmerinnen und unternehmer
mutlos werden weil sie so lange
schließen möchten wenn die man sich
selbständig macht dann macht er das weil
er gerne den menschen die haare schön
macht und wenn er einen gast stephan und
restaurant eröffnet weil er gerne für
sie kocht oder gerne geselligkeit hat
und all diese menschen sind verzweifelt
weil sie wollen ja unternehmerinnen oder
unternehmer sein und das tut mir so weh
wir haben in deutschland viel zu wenig
menschen die sich selbständig machen
in den letzten jahren immer gehabt und
meine große sorge ist dass wir den einen
oder anderen verlieren den wir dringend
brauchen weil sie so einen großartigen
beitrag leisten zu unserer kultur und zu
unserer identität jetzt haben wir eine
längere diskussion schon erlebt im land
über fußballspieler zum beispiel die
immer wieder mal die haare geschnitten
hatten auch über fernsehmoderatoren die
immer mal wieder ihre haare geschnitten
hatten und auch über die bundeskanzlerin
die vergangene woche im interview gesagt
hat mensch ich habe meine assistentin so
war ihre ihre formulierung in diesem
interview
wie ja viele wissen ich habe da ja
bekanntermaßen unterstützung durch eine
assistentin die macht die frisur ist
vermutlich auch geprüft hat doch keiner
aber vermutlich alles legal und trotzdem
frau klingsporn man kann so ein bisschen
verstehen wenn man da auf der zinne ist
man selber steht mit der schere oder dem
rasierer in der hand möchte wieder ran
und
ganz ganz viele millionen deutsche
warten auf die termine wieder bei ihnen
und die kanzlerin kriegt die frisur
gemacht ich kann da der kollegin die das
gemacht hat nur gratulieren die da hilft
sozusagen
ich frage mich wo ist der unterschied
zwischen einer hilfe und der kanzlerin
und wo ist der unterschied zwischen
mitarbeitern die bei uns arbeiten
wie hängt man das was seehofer hat es
auf den punkt gebracht er hat gesagt
öffnet die friseure den die
schwarzarbeit wächst was sagen sie dazu
ich glaube dass das ein sehr ernstes
argument ist ich habe mit dem kollegen
seehofer habe mich darüber auch schon
vor 14 tagen drei wochen ausgetauscht
weil wir beide eigentlich ziemlich
ziemlich im richtigen leben verwurzelt
sind und wissen was im richtigen leben
vor sich geht und ich glaube in der tat
wenn es schwarzarbeit gibt dann ist das
gesundheitlich natürlich viel
gravierender als wenn sie in einen
friseursalon kommen wo alle
hygienevorschriften eingehalten sind und
alles bestens vorbereitet das heißt wenn
die drei ehrlichen die gerade vor ihnen
sind altmaier wenn die alle jetzt
schwarz arbeiten würden und das würde
die ganze branche machen im moment
machen es nur einige wenn es die ganze
branche machen würden dann wäre es das
beste argument wieder zu öffnen
also erstmal ist es so dass wir hier
nicht von ein paar schwarzen schafen auf
die ganze branche schließen dürfen
ich weiß dass die allermeisten ehrlich
sind zweitens wenn diese schwarzen
schafe auffallen dann müssen sie auch
mit ordnungs und bußgeldern rechnen aber
je mehrere schafe es gibt das ist dass
die aggression von herrn seehofer ja
mehr druck zu öffnen ich weiß wie wir
wir wir haben alle diese wir haben alle
diese dringenden wünsche vor uns und
jetzt diskutieren wir hier mit den
friseuren
ich kann das verstehen aber es gibt auch
ganz viele tausend gastwirte genauso
viele reife kommen wir auch sagen und
sagen meint mein restaurant ich klar das
stinkt nachricht nach abgestandenem bier
und abgestandenem essen weil wir eben
dort
seit vier monaten nicht lange war die
drei vor allen dingen jahren klingen
spur hat ja nicht nur gesagt herr
altmaier
sie müssen unbedingt die friseure wieder
aufmachen natürlich ist dass das
geschäft der drei und natürlich wünschen
sie sich dass aber die haben vor allen
dingen eines gesagt wir brauchen eine
perspektive
wir wollen unseren kunden irgendwie
sagen solange noch das war das
hauptargument hat sich das aber ganz
sicher auch davon aus dass die
perspektive bald kommt wir arbeiten ja
eröffnungs konzepten die bundesländer
tun dass das kanzleramt ist ich tue es
als bundeswirtschaftsminister und wir
überlegen fangen wir an bei diesem oder
jenem mit je fangen wir an dort wo die
zahlen ganz niedrig da wird man das nach
der nach dem mittwochstermin wissen also
weiß frau klingspor wenn folgende
voraussetzungen bei mir in münchen
erfüllt sind dann darf ich mein salon
wieder öffnen weiß sie dass nach dieser
woche also nach irgendwo wenn ich das
wüsste
weil der mittwoch sind noch drei tage
aber es ist das sehr zielgenau das tor
nein wir müssen wir müssen uns darüber
verständigen in welcher wenn es gut geht
nach welchen prinzipien und kriterien
wie eröffnungen vorbereiten
aber ich würde davor warnen zu sagen wir
öffnen die frist jetzt schon zu sagen
wir öffnen die gaststätten vor dem hotel
soll die hotels wurde in gaststätten
weil ich genau weiß dass diejenigen die
dann später geöffnet werden total
verzweifelt sein werden und sagen was
haben wir denn angestellt dass es uns so
trifft und deshalb wäre es ja eigentlich
ganz gut man könnte auch lockerungen in
gang setzen
die mehrere branchen betreffen und da
muss man sich auch sehr genau die
regionale situation anschauen wenn sie
einen landkreis haben ganz wenig
infektionen sind und in allen
landkreisen drumherum auch nicht dann
ist es eine andere situation als wenn
sie einen haben muss gerade noch
einigermaßen okay so nebendran ist ein
super hot spot mit über 300 ansteckungen
pro 100000 einwohner also verstehen sie
sich von selbst verstehen sie an mit den
ländern absprechen und ich wünsche mir
dass die länder die kraft haben dies so
zu entscheiden dass es in jedem
bundesland einheitlich angewendet wird
weil das schlimmste ist wenn dann die
menschen mich anrufen und sagen herr
altmaier ich komme aus rheinland pfalz
oder aus baden württemberg und bei uns
müssen wir noch nicht mal und die
anderen dürfen schon jetzt morgen bei
ihnen kundinnen anrufen oder kunden
anrufen frau sehr schick und sie fragen
was hat er denn jetzt gesagt könnten sie
es sagen also könnten sie es ihren
kunden sagen der altmeiler meint das so
wird es laufen also ich werde
wahrscheinlich halbstündig telefonate
führen dass mit einer halben stunde
dauern bis ich das verstanden habe so
wie ich verstehe den kunden das
rüberzubringen
es wird lange schwierig sein den kunden
das verständlich zu machen
so jetzt einmal eine ganz andere sache
wir waren legal ite da will ich noch mal
ganz kurz in die verfolgungsjagd hat
auch angefangen es sind kunden die uns
wirklich oder mich zumindest wirklich
verfolgen und sagen können sie mir die
haare bitte zu hause schneider können
sie bitte dieses mein beruf ist zur zeit
illegal und das muss ich wirklich sagen
verletzt mal wäre also es ist wirklich
die zeit mal ausdrücklich zu sagen wir
müssen jetzt mal wirklich sagen was
machen wir ärzte pflegepersonal die
arbeiten alle auch so nah wir sind
dienstleister also herr altmaier sie
haben sozusagen sie nicht sie persönlich
aber sie haben den friseurberuf zu einem
illegalen beruf gemacht sagt frau feld
schicken nein heißt nein das kann man so
nicht sagen weil die menschen sich an
die gesetze halten müssen
davon gehen wir auch aus und es gibt ja
auch ganz viele andere körpernahe
dienstleistungen die geschlossen sind
und zwar schon seit langem
fitnessstudios beispielsweise und und
andere massagepraxen und alle sagen wann
dürfen wir wieder öffnen und ich wäre
ein schlechter wirtschaftsminister wenn
ich sagen würde die friseure auf jeden
fall und die anderen müssen mal schauen
irgendwann weil ich die sorgen und die
not der friseure verstehe aber glauben
sie mir die fitness studios waren
geschlossen bis weit in den sommer und
in den herbst in einigen bundesländern
und sind wieder geschlossen seit dem
ersten november
sie haben demnächst ein jahr in dem sie
kein geld verdient haben die
veranstaltungs betriebe die messe
ausrichter sind ein ganzes jahr so es
gibt durch
diese pandemie so entsetzlich viele
dramen die entstanden sind und deshalb
versuchen wir das ab zu lindern und zu
finden zu helfen wo wir können
wir haben 20 milliarden 23 milliarden an
kurzarbeiter geld ausgegeben
das geht nicht an die unternehmer das
geht an die beschäftigten natürlich aber
es hilft auch die beschäftigten zu
halten dass man wieder loslegen kann
wenn die öffnung möglich ist okay einmal
strich drunter ich will noch einmal das
ganz kurz mit der kanzlerin aufnehmen ja
ist das finden sie das eigentlich völlig
in ordnung finden sie das völlig in
ordnung weil die kanzlerin ist weil sie
stark weil sie in der öffentlichkeit
steht oder ist es schon komisch und
vielleicht auch moralisch ein bisschen
nicht mehr ganz sauber wenn sie die
geschichte der drei hören na ja wissen
sie als ich heute abend zu ihnen rein
gebeten worden bin und dann hat man mich
in einen kleinen raum gebracht wo eine
maskenbild ganz genau
die mit großer professionalität dafür
gesorgt hat dass ich von weitem
einigermaßen entfernt aussehe
und ich habe auch schon beim talk shows
erlebt wenn ich dann irgendwo ein paar
strähnen hatte die abstanden dass die
maskenbildnerin die eine friseur
ausbildung hatte dank gesagt hat das
schneiden war gleich ab und ganz ähnlich
ist es mit der kanzlerin auch dass das
auch erwartet wird dass sie in der
öffentlichkeit ihr land repräsentiert
und vertritt
ich glaube das hat sie auch ganz ehrlich
und offen gesagt und auch bild oder oder
nicht die der springer konzern hat
gesagt ja bei uns ist das auch so wir
haben auch maskenbildner und die sind im
einsatz das kann man diskutieren man
kann sagen warum geht der
wirtschaftsminister nicht mal mit langen
haaren zu den richtigen fragen oder herr
weise und anderen aber ich die dass das
dass das problem ändert sich dadurch
nicht das eben millionen von menschen
sehnsüchtig daraus entsteht halt da
dachten wir dass ein friseur gehen
müssen das jetzt gar nicht an der
kanzlerin fest machen aber wir waren
auch über fernsehmoderatoren sprechen
über youtube usw
wenn man den fernseher anmacht
beispielsweise hat man manchmal das
gefühl da ist gar kein locker und oder
wenn man sieht am flughafen dass eine
klientel nach dubai fliegt und dort nach
wie vor urlaub macht
da gilt dann plötzlich kein lockdown
aber es gilt halt für millionen deutsche
hier lockt dann hat sich so eine zwei
klassen gesellschaft etabliert die einen
die sich an die regeln halten müssen und
für die anderen gilt irgendwie dann doch
einen weg dass die regel doch nicht so
ganz gehören also ich finde dass es auch
dass es auch geschmacklosigkeiten gibt
und dass jeder der der etwas tun kann
was vielleicht egal es sich immer auch
fragen muss ob man das in anderen
zumuten kann ob das ein gutes beispiel
ist
ich bin zum beispiel mein eigenes haus
ist im saarland
ich wohne dort alleine da muss ich ab
und an mal hin alle paar wochen ich habe
das als der lok dann besonders scharf
war so gemacht dass ich eben nicht im
flieger geflogen bin sondern selbst mit
meinem auto gefahren bin wo ich
niemanden getroffen habe und niemanden
gefährdet habe und ich weiß dass ganz
viele menschen das ähnlich tun und ich
glaube es ist jetzt auch nicht der
richtige zeitpunkt um nach dubai oder
anderswohin zu fahren sondern es ist der
zeitpunkt zu zeigen dass wir verstanden
stehen verstehe jetzt wollen wir einmal
ganz kurzen abschluss machen mit frau
celtic mit frau klotz und mit frau
klingspor der wirtschaftsminister hat
sich hier erklärt hat auch erklärt warum
die eine oder andere hilfe die sie so
dringend brauchen noch nicht geflossen
ist was können sie halt mal den dreien
heute abend mit auf den weg gehen wenn
sie sich nicht mehr solche sorgen machen
müssen wenn sie vielleicht ein bisschen
ruhigere nächte haben also die
überbrückungshilfe drei habe ich gesagt
die soll bis ende februar
anträge und abschlagszahlung und dann
natürlich ab märz die richtigen
auszahlungen kurzarbeitergeld ist
gesichert bis ende des jahres und wir
wollen öffnen sobald es vertretbar ist
aber das kann man nicht vier wochen im
voraus wissen und wenn die zahlen weiter
so sinken wie jetzt
und wenn die mutationen sich nicht
ausbreiten wie die pest dann glaube ich
das licht am ende des tunnels jetzt so
langsam sichtbar wird leider noch vage
der wirtschaftsminister hat erklärt aus
seiner sicht warum das so ist es ist im
moment bleibt noch unbefriedigend frau
klingspor celtic klotz danke ihnen dass
sie das gespräch gesucht haben heute
abend mit dem wirtschaftsminister